welt seid mir gegrüßt ich bin mal wann
er in berlin fast im herzen von europa
die fantastischen tag und schob sich mit
geburtsort richtig die 7 6 390 aus dem
hause lego der adventskalender
ja
aber vorher trinke ich noch mal raus aus
der helden tasse schmeckt alles besser
an dieser stelle danke thomas dass du
mir diese wunderbare tasse geschickt
hast ich wollte sie in seinem onlineshop
kaufen hab sie nicht bekommt haben die
daran geschrieben wie denn an diese
tasse kommen und dann hat er mir
freundlicherweise eine tasse zugeschickt
und ich muss sagen es schmeckt wirklich
alles besser raus und jetzt alle diese
tasse ist nicht gesponsert genauso wenig
wie dieser adventskalender von lego ich
kann mich ehrlich gesagt nicht daran
erinnern wann ich das letzte mal lego
selbst gebaut hat es muss mindestens
vielleicht war ich zehn aber lieber hat
in letzter zeit öfter meinen weg
gekreuzt einmal mit dieser lego wars
serie
diese liga us show auf rtl
[Musik]
die müssen da halt immer so große
gebilde bauen und dann war das halt ganz
cool und dann haben wir uns jede folge
angeschaut und dann haben wir noch in
der mediathek letzte staffel angeschaut
und für die extra noch bezahlt habe und
dass plötzlich so interessiert hat und
natürlich durch den hält der steine der
held der steine ist ein
mensch thomas pankl der hat ein lego
laden oder einbau klemm baustein laden
und ja und ich gucke mir seine videos
zum einschlafen ich weiß nicht warum ich
kann dabei super schaffen welcher 45
minuten lang etwas überlegen erzählt
oder für irgendwo über irgendwelche
sachen da ich kann es auch nicht
erklären manchmal kommt sie ins
schlafzimmer und tat an studie hält er
steige der ihnen da freundlich begrüßt
welt zeigt million grinst ich bin der
held der stein wird jeder hat doch so
sein denken aber als es dann darum gehen
was wert wenn sulander ich dieses jahr
auspacke musste ich natürlich ein lego
adventskalender besorgen er ist jetzt
aus der harry potter serie
harry potter macht ja sehr viel mit le
bo also lebe und harry potter machen ja
sehr viel zusammen die sind so und ich
habe mich lange überlegt dieses hogwarts
schloss von lego zu holen aber zeit viel
geld wie bin sicher deswegen kamen die
kleinen allerdings client mit dem
adventskalender sieben jahren ist dieser
adventskalender ich weiß nicht ob es für
junge erwachsene oder erwachsene noch
was wäre wir finden es raus machen wir
erstmal wollen wir den preislisten der
preis liegt aktuell bei der ausverkauf
also usd verkaufen einfach nur sehr
viele ja für den adventskalender 23 eur
81 bezahlt ich glaube aber jetzt ist er
sogar teurer also da kriegt man den
teilweise für 30 euro ist der preis
schwankt da sehr doll müsst ihr einfach
mal schauen wenn ihr euch den jetzt
abholen wollte bevor ich jetzt noch
hundertmal niveau sage dieses videos
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
videos nicht gesprochen sagt und
anfangen das ist ein sehr leichter ins
klo das bin ich nicht gewohnt die
adventskalender die sonst ihr habt die
sind die meisten die hier habe sind
eindeutig schwer heute eben wirklich
liebe harry potter es ist einfach so
muss auch dieses jahr unbedingt wieder
ein harry potter film abend machen ich
hätte das letztes jahr schon gemacht am
wochenende samstag vormittag angefangen
und bis sonntagabend mit schlafen
dazwischen natürlich positiv wir haben
hier hogwarts bedeckt im schnee und eine
plattform vorne dran so nicole hosp
interplay das ist glaube ich
gleichzeitig auch ein spiel gibt noch
mal ein bisschen die kamera dann könnt
ihr mir von tischen und schon sehen wir
das ganze ding
total okay wir fangen an mädchen nummer
eins sind aufregend ich habe schon lange
jetzt davon geträumt lego in der hand zu
haben die nummer eins die anleitung ist
in der tür sind laut hilfe nummer eins
mit aufdruck was für eine premiere
und schon fällt mir das erste ding weg
aber 4000 super einsteigermodells 100
bands können daran besitzt da dieses
[Musik]
spiel spaß und spannung kam und es kommt
ein vorne hin und her und konnte brief
ja ich bestätige seiten erzählt dass wie
lego ausgeguckt haben
von
david drive was ins deutsche übersetzt
wurde mit ligusterweg
erste erfahrung war nett war ganz nett
und wir haben wir schon den heribert da
kann ich euch nicht sagen wie viele
teile dieses ding hat und auch dass ich
den preis nicht lohnt da ja wir müssen
jetzt mit einem zauber zusammenführen
und euch meinen fingernägeln aufgefallen
dankeschön ja das kriege ich hin das ist
sind einfach nur menschen zusammen
stecken also wenn ich das nicht
hinbekommen cool harry hat sogar zwei
emotionen
die nette
und merke ich jetzt natürlich sieht man
eben auge dass das obenrum bedruckt ist
und warum nicht und das ist völlig okay
weil das ganz gut aus hier herrscht eine
kritisiert dass manchmal das was bei
lego nicht gedruckt ist sondern dass man
sticker drauf machen der kalender wird
er kindlich aber mit sieben hat man noch
nicht harry potter so konsumieren oder
zehn vielleicht jetzt wird komplizierter
da wohne ich mir die anleitung unter die
wm also eine anleitung ja
ja das ist wohl das ist kompliziert auch
okay wir fangen manche mit diesem
vorderen ging an so wir brauchen das
braune da kommt diese kleinen nobels ran
doch jetzt hört nur kreativität auch
schon auf dem feld das brauche ich das
brauche ich das ist oben das habe ich
keine ahnung das sehe ich nicht wo das
steckt warum habe ich drei der acht mal
die drei miteinander gehören a ha mit
michael most of the boxmasters
legamaster schiesst sion
ich muss man richtig sein hirn
anstrengen das muss man ja weniger
reichen club damit das fest hier sitzt
aber das ist einer übrig ich habe jetzt
so einem kleinen übrig und drei macht
vier männer viel spaß tür hier nochmal
für noch mehr briefe
eine ahnung was er sein soll einen
briten
von hogwarts letter dann haben wir halt
drei stücke haben wir eine schaufel war
soll das hinten haben wir ein so ein
goldenes ding und so ein rotes teil was
uns drauf so schenk nicht was dieses
grüne ding sein soll wenn sie entweder
bin ich blöd auf beiden augen oder
einfach nur doof was ist dass sich
jackson hinten besen im besten fall hat
das kind ja dann schon lege oder der
erwachsenen und freut sich dann wenn wir
die nummer zwei wir sehen hier ja okay
das ist vielleicht ganz cool
den hab ich ja auch selber schon mal
gebacken wenn ihr sehen wollt wie ich
den gebacken hat dann schaut auf das
youtube videos ist so klein das zeug
happy birthday damit kriegt dem ich lege
ich werde besser ich merke schon gesagt
habt ihr dann hier ein kuchen drücke wir
haben kirche die nummer 6 nicolas und
wir bekommen
bekommt ein freund
beine auf drauf wieder zwei gesichter
ich habe mich für das typische gesicht
sorry leute natürlich da die ja klar hat
leader seinen kuchen futter
jetzt lesen sagen wir die nummer 7 und
40 7 ist ein schild trug drauf stange
rahn zum treffen in kemel also hier
stets auf englisch wiki irgendwas aber
dass das tropfende kessel steht ihr wenn
man das dann ist herstellung kombinieren
die türchen rand in europa hat er auch
ein bisschen rebellion niveau was ist
das denn das erkennt man ja nicht mal
dass ein tisch an tisch
an coolen kleinen glasflasche
sag
das mal laufen beim trocknen
ok nächste türchen nummer 9 und es wird
hier schon perfekt nummer 9 meine
absolute lieblingsstadt was steckt in
der neuen ihr dürft es zuerst sehen drei
sekunden die zahl zu raten spaß das ist
einige kassen mauer hat die auch das
gefühl dass harry potter fans immer sehr
dollar betonen müssen dass sie alles
über harry potter
also wenn sie etwas hören dann sagen sie
gleich die antwort und eine frage kann
ich einfach ein traum mal gestellt
werden es muss sofort beantwortet werden
mit der betonung ich weiß alles über ein
portal was die leute meine oder machen
da so eine platte und dann kommt so eine
platte wieder toll was läge somit eine
macht
den letzten stein macht ihr mit mir
drauf
ist das sparen
mir fehlt was aber hätte ich da nicht
zwei fans dürfen
ich habe hier schon wieder ein übrig
warum habe ich immer ein übrig ich
stelle mir das bei der wichtigsten frage
wie schmeckt können unsere mauer
und dann geht sie auf was mache ich hier
gerade leute es macht spaß dort könne
leipzig nochmals 10 ich würde sagen der
schalter bei gringotts aber ja
es ist der erste richtige legostein so
wie ich lego im komfort bull teams leute
good old times
keine ahnung wie dieser gutheisst
handelt
wird was genau sind das für teile
gucken was kommt dabei hat ohne
schlüssel weil er sich natürlich um die
verliese im gringotts kümmert und dann
so aufschließen wenn du dein bankkonto
möchtest nicht digital der jetzt auch so
zwei böse blicke einmal einmal dass sein
böses gesicht und einmal hat er so eins
aber er guckt immer böse ich gebe ihnen
beides trifft aber mein gerade mensing
damit diese ganzen einzelteile nicht
herumfliegen kriegt harry jetzt einen
besen und schaufel sobald sie gut fest
ich merke gerade dass ich so meine
verlorene kindheit hier wieder
zurückfinden sind wir hereinkommen
tücher noch mal 12 und darin befindet
sich ein weit teil fünf
dinger sind wir hier bei lego technic
angekommen oder warum baue ich jetzt mit
rädern
ich habe mich gerade daran erinnert was
ich das letzte mal mit leo gemacht habt
und zwar wenn ich ins legoland dänemark
gefahren mit meiner familie da war ich
wirklich
10 oder so neuen look at me by profi
hier am werk als ob sie nie was anderes
gemacht hätte
bei dem ding jetzt sogar die lampe hier
sucht tiefer stellen
das paar wird mich so toll dass wir
immer waren übrig bleibt die normale
reizen lebt absolut keine ahnung was das
sein soll
es hat aber sehr viele teile diese
dinger sind so klein dass man es
überhaupt nicht zeigen kann hier ist ein
stück runde ecke sagt sagt natürlich
vanessa der lehre pro wie hier am start
dann haben wir hier diese fantastischen
app dinge die das nur hier festhalten
irgendwelche greifarme wie soll ich
keine ahnung was es sein soll so kommt
da nicht raus
es ist schon wieder so ein teil übrig
und kneten die ausbeutung aber was ist
das 13 und 14 auch hier also hat die 14
etwas damit zu tun oder was natürlich
immer 14 das gefällt uns doch einfach
nur golden wir den schatz gefunden
ach so und hier stapeln wie jetzt
einfach unsere moneten drauf das ist
harrys verließ so haben wir viel gold
so aber wie fügt man das wenn jetzt
zusammen ist dass sie 13 14 aber hier
zeigten die nicht hier ist dann am ende
dann zeigt das doch so drauf nein
vielleicht könnt ihr auch bei dem video
einfach gut einschlafen wer war jetzt ja
keine ahnung irgendwas mit einem
zauberstab ist ein zauber stadt intuit
und ein buch ist buch
ab jetzt war in der winkelgasse hat sich
gold geholt und jetzt kaufte sich sind
schuld materialien und unterstützt
kleine tom gestartet jetzt aber klein
die mit meiner in fester hand könnt ihr
den supersüßen zauberstab sehen oh mein
gott leute wie konnte ich denn denken
dass es nur will es erstens macht es
keinen sinn von dem setting aber da hat
sogar sein kleines schwein ziehen hier
muss dennoch her gut kommen hinzu
erwischt kommt in diesem
und co dieses kleine buch an die kinder
ein kleines buch 16
jawoll okay die geschichte dahinter
stecke ich jetzt auch jetzt gibt es die
eule lieblich und ein kleiner shokof ist
eine garde versorgungsraumschiff theke
plattformen nur dreiviertel jahr für
nicht gut 17 ihres spielfeld auch
einfach abschneiden können merke ich
gerade hier so oder so eine schere
aufgezeigt wer das ist schon wieder
irgend so ein wagen
ist dass der paket fragen für die
plattform den kleinwagen ich finde jetzt
nicht okay wie soll man das nachstellen
können
und wie trifft er am bahnhof natürlich
war louis lee wieso haben ron weasley
viel zauberstäbe am start dank regis
natürlich augen schon gefreut mit seiner
karte ins team stoßen 19 das schild für
gleis 9 3 fertig ist und an harry potter
copy video gemacht und ich weiß noch
nicht ob es schon online ist oder ob es
noch erst komme aber ich bin jetzt
wieder komplett und harry potter
stimmung mit dem kalender sowieso fast
drauf das braucht des 3
jetzt kämen nur noch das schild und
fertig das akzeptiere ich in tokios so
wir sind in den 20 jahren angekommen
türchen nochmals 20
termine hat vier neue zauberstäben starb
mein hirn ist auf es ist ein bisschen
spät ab 18 uhr das für mich schon spät
seite so früh dunkel geworden ist
wirklich es ist eine qual armen hat 16
uhr bin ich nicht mehr zu gebrauchen ich
denke dann wirklich mein ganzer körper
ist einfach nur noch auf wobei jetzt
macht nichts mehr was auch nichts mehr
lust
jetzt ist sie auf gelb und die haare
drauf
und du kommst hier zu haben 21 also wir
sind jetzt ja eigentlich schon kurz vor
hogwarts express am bildschirm hobbys
oder ist das der familie nachholt und
jetzt will erstmal gefressen
das ist ja toll durch sagt man jetzt
diesen tisch
keiner dran eine aus gold natürlich das
können sich nur damit
tut mir leid wie alle leute die schon
länger kennen aber
das paket lässt sich allerdings nicht
befestigung des katholiken ein kleiner
kürbis ja und jetzt ist es teilweise
verloren haben was davon
verloren
ich verstehe nicht
wo arid das auf ist das eine formel
arbeit was ist das denn hans bald schon
drauf gepackt hat kriege wiebe
zurücklegen die kirchen da oben drauf
oder wie ist da bin ich schon wieder
sind
die kirchen kann haben 22
nein
ist das etwa unser erz rivale
bis jetzt war alles noch so gut aber
jetzt kommt mehr erfolg bringt uns
liegen hier zwar glaubt lego weiß dass
man diese zauberstäbe schnell verliert
weil die so klein sind regen geben sie
einen gleich 100 mit das ist so geil
dass ihm elf eigentlich so weiß blonde
haare machen wollten und er in den
ersten film einfach gelbe hatte der
erste dass da hat er so schlecht könnte
daher und ich sehe da einen krassen gelb
stehe ich das ist ein zeichen von
falsche produkt anwendung so
haben sie meinen katzen
machen
schaut mich an wie ein profi chris
müssen
das ist der tannenbaum oh tannenbaum oh
tannenbaum wie
plastik sind deine blätter und jetzt
sind wir schon beim letzten angekommen
darf gegen ja schnell leute jetzt ist
der 24 hier wir haben heiligabend wir
bekommen den drei- oder
yahoo doch nicht mal gucken ob dieser
3-lauf funktioniert es geht voll auf die
finger ich verstehe nicht wie sie bei
lego masters stundenlang sie klemm
bausteine drücken konnten wir tun jetzt
schon die finger weg wie kann das sein
soll die farben des hauses also ledig
jetzt noch mal die letzte frage an euch
jetzt wo ich hier gerade die farben des
hauses run klippe welches haus seite
weiß ich ob ich meine es schon verraten
sollte sagt der griff und fertiges und
23 nun stellen wir uns wieder dixon
frage funktioniert dieser drei will auch
der dritte
mann
[Musik]
- 2 heißt es man kann zu 5 ok also
dieses spiel besteht also es ist
wirklich nur so ein wie viele schritte
kann man gehen spielt und dann sind die
figuren die man da hat die figuren ist
ganz nett
kinder bestimmt also ich das gefeiert da
passiert halt nicht fehlen damit er mich
einen karten aufdecken oder sollten
deswegen ist es halt nur drei schritte
nach vorne zwei zurück 3 2 vorne
aber weil sie mal die 3d benutzt
ja jetzt fehlt nur noch mein resümiert
23 euro bezahlt ich denke für 23 euro
finde ich es ok ich kenne mich leider
nicht mit lego preisen aus deswegen ja
müsst ihr geld in die kommentare
schreiben ob es sich lohnt vielleicht
schreibt der hater steine auch ein
kommentar das war ernst nimmt dann kann
es ja mal sagen ich fahre jetzt das
aufbauen ja süß es hat spaß gemacht
nächstes cooler als der kuchen von
hellgate und wenn man schon le bo heart
und das quasi so als erweiterung jetzt
viele harry potter figuren und hogwarts
briefe und so dann kann man damit ihr
auch spielen ich weiß nicht inwiefern
leute noch immer mit lego spielen also
kinder bestimmt schon
erwachsene machen das ja eher als hobby
zum bauen und sammeln
aber als kind hätte ich mich mega
gefreut sehen noch nicht so ganz diese
überschneidung von harry potter und
kindern die das dann hat auch innere ja
weil die kinder habt könnt ihr sie haben
eine kommentare schreiben würde sich das
für euer kind lohnen oder nicht und
ansonsten sehen uns beim nächsten video
via bis dann nach und leute
333 will muss den radl drehen wo habe
ich diesen euro
keine ahnung
das könnte ein gutes trainingsspiel sein
okay ist